I've learned to embrace the fact that
basic anxieties I'm not deal talking
about dealing with severe mental health
issues but basic anxiety is a part of
life you know anxiety uh has gotten me
where I am today you know uh not wanting
to mess up at school being anxious about
doing what I'm supposed to do you know
making sure I'm not living on the street
so I want to be able to have a job that
kind of anxiety you know it propels me
forward
um but I've also learned that sometimes
I gotta just step out of the noise
um and and know that I have to turn off
the things that cause me upset so there
are times even in the white house where
I just had to not hear anything you know
I didn't want to hear about the country
through the voice of someone else I I A
lot of times I let my experiences with
the American people shape my attitude